[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ces sommes sont inquiets depuis déjà une
demi journée ils sont bloqués à 3000 m
d'altitude au beau milieu des neiges
éternelles leur peur être obligé de
passer la nuit en pleine montagne par
-10° carla loarie rebaptisé la route de
l'enfer vient de s'effondrer
les automobilistes n'ont pas d'autre
choix que de la reconstruire par eux
mêmes cet endroit est très dangereux et
la route ferme tout le temps ce matin il
venait d'ouvrir
et déjà elle s'effondre alors par nous
mêmes
et si dieu le veut on pourra bientôt
partir vas-y avance avance doucement
vas-y il aura fallu sept heures aux
automobilistes pour colmater la brèche
la route est de nouveau praticable mais
pour combien de temps
situé dans les zones tribales du
nord-ouest pakistan la ville de dire est
le point de départ de la halle aux arts
ea longue de 240 km cette route est
l'unique point de passage à travers la
montagne pour ravitailler la vallée de
chitral essai petit village mitoyen avec
l'afghanistan
[Musique]
une route où la moindre erreur
d'inattention peut s'avérer fatale
angels la route la plus dangereuse je
suis la plus vicieuse
sd c'est la loire il aurait passe
grave accident arrive là bas les
conducteurs sont tués j'en avais peur de
cette route
bien sûr qu'on en a peur on a même peur
d'y mourir
dieu est grand il va nous aider à passer
ils le font
[Musique]
mais passe une vitesse passe une vitesse
devenu curé ou quoi
pour
ils sont toujours très inquiet de partir
sur cette route
inquiet de ne jamais revoir leur maison
de ne jamais retrouver leurs enfants
[Musique]
à
sur cette route un accident peut
survenir à tout moment et l'état
dire la pieuse et ses vingt mille âmes
vivent principalement de la route
toute la journée des tonnes de
marchandises sont chargés et déchargés
des camions unique moyen de transport de
la région
le quartier des camionneurs est la
principale source d'emplois conducteur
mécanicien assistant de tout âge il
travaille chaque jour dans la poussière
et la pollution
à 23 ans camara a bien réussi dans la
vie il est déjà propriétaire de deux
camions ce matin il est inquiet son
camion va s'engager sur la loarie il
doit livrer deux tonnes de sucre au
petit village de chitral ce voyage
périlleux il l'a confié à son meilleur
chauffeur
représente daou c'est mon chauffeur je
le paye 40 euros par mois il travaille
avec son petit frère
c'est une bonne équipe s'ils sont très
courageux 40 euros par mois c'est le
salaire moyen au pakistan à ce prix là
peu de chauffeur accepte de risquer leur
vie sur cette route
alors pour trouver des candidats camara
offre une prime de risque de 60 euros
par trajet une prime qui motive les plus
jeunes voilà khalid c'est le petit frère
de daou il fait l'assistant pendant le
trajet mais quatorze ans ce pas trop
jeune c'est la pauvreté qui l'obligent
il n'y a pas d'autres activités existent
quel est le rôle de ton petit frère il
s'occupe des manoeuvres difficiles en
indiquant les directions ne prévient des
problèmes sur la route et s'occupe de la
mécanique
[Musique]
et il travaille bien oui car s'il fait
mal son travail je lui apprendrai pas à
conduire le camion
7 heures du matin doutzen le départ
[Applaudissements]
voyager sur la lowery est loin d'être
une partie de plaisir sur 240 kilomètres
la route serpente à travers la montagne
et ses corniches vertigineuse
logiquement il faut une journée pour en
arriver à bon mais peu de chauffeurs y
parviennent
doubt veut pourtant la franchir le plus
rapidement possible au mépris du danger
salut mec son objectif est de multiplier
les allers retours afin de cumuler les
primes de risque
pour y parvenir il ne s'arrête jamais et
passe sa vie dans son camion
entre le camion et moi c'est une
relation extrêmement forte
il est comme ma maison je mange je dors
ici
en fait je passe plus de temps à son
bord que chez mois d'aout conduit depuis
bientôt dix ans le camion lui n'a plus
d'âge le compteur est d'ailleurs resté
bloqué sur 776 1000 km depuis bien
longtemps
peu importe les deux frères l'ont
décorée comme leur propre maison
les photos de feu benazir buttho ils
partagent l'espace avec celle de pop
star indienne idole de la jeunesse
pakistanaise
à 2000 mètres d'altitude les premières
difficultés surviennent
la fonte des neiges forme des torrents
qui coupent creuse et emporte la route
sur des centaines de mètres pour
franchir ce torrent on avance en
première
très très doucement à cause des trous au
fond de l'eau quelles sont vraiment les
risques quand on est chargé comme
aujourd'hui on risque de casser l'arbre
de direction
mais pire que tout on risque de se
renverser
à chaque passage dangereux les pneus
sont déformés entaillée par les rochers
alors khalid les vérifie un par un pour
éviter tout éclatement
sur la loire il les problèmes ne
s'arrêtent jamais alors pour les oublier
les chauffeurs fume la drogue local
[Musique]
quand je file du haschich
je ne pense plus à la route
tous les problèmes que je vais bientôt
rencontrer
mais en plus je ne réfléchis même plus
au danger
la tête dans les nuages doubt devient un
danger supplémentaire sur la route de
nombreux accidents sont causés par cette
consommation de drogue
devant le nombre croissant de blessés
sur la loire y le gouvernement
pakistanais a entrepris depuis quatre
ans de creuser un tunnel à travers la
montagne
on traversera bientôt la montagne ça va
vraiment de changer la vie comme ça on
aura moins difficultés pour travailler
mais pour l'instant on doit continuer à
franchir le col à plus de 3000 mètres
d'altitude et on ne sait jamais si on
réussira à passer
daoud habite à quelques pas de ce
chantier avant d'attaquer la montagne
il s'arrête toujours pour embrasser ses
enfants sa vie
c'est sur la route qu'elles défilent tu
les vois souvent tes fils pas
malheureusement pas beaucoup
et eux ils seront conducteur est
peut-être
daouda deux garçons et une fille dans
cette vallée très à cheval sur la
religion on oblige les femmes à se
cacher du regard des hommes
dawood empêchera même sa mère sa femme
et sa fille de nous rencontrer
comment tu vois ton avenir et il n'y a
pas d'avenir ici on travaille c'est tout
on n'y a pas d'avenir dans ce job mais
tu voudrais pas acheter un camion un
jour je gagne tout juste de quoi nourrir
ma famille alors comment veux tu que
j'économise pour un camion moi je vais
économiser 30 mille euros et je vais
l'acheter ce camion sera de faire de
décoration il ouvrira ce sera le premier
camion de la famille dès que j'ai de
l'argent je l'achète
[Applaudissements]
après deux heures d'arrêt les deux
frères reprenne la route
ils attaquent maintenant la partie la
plus difficile de l'ascension une zone
où la fonte des neige provoque avalanche
et glissements de terrain
[Applaudissements]
en moins d'une heure ils vont passer de
2000 à 3000 m d'altitude
[Musique]
une ascension à donner le vertige aux
routiers les plus aguerris
ainsi quelle ils descendraient la route
a pas l'air bonne devant
le camion peine
sur les pentes abruptes la vitesse tombe
à dix kilomètres heure
2800 m le manque d'oxygène accentue la
fatigue et diminue la concentration
[Musique]
le moindre geste devient alors un effort
il faut lutter pour rester éveillé
[Musique]
encore 300 mètres avant le col et son
auberge
[Musique]
ça y est on est arrivé au sommet fait
vraiment froid ici regarde là bas c'est
la zone des 45 virage la descente est
terrible c'est vraiment très dangereux
il faut freiner tout le temps et les
freins chauffe la route est si étroite
que dans les virages on ne peut même pas
se croiser avec d'autres camions alors
il faut être attentif et ne jamais lâché
son volant n'ont jamais devant l'auberge
du col les camionneurs vérifient que
leurs marchandises sont bien arrivés à
l'intérieur d'autres évacuent les
tensions de la montée et se prépare pour
la suite
devant un bon plat de moutons bouillie
la spécialité de la vallée quelles sont
les qualités indispensables pour
traverser la montagne il faut avoir le
coeur solide
c'est à dire il faut du courage et de
l'expérience
celui qui n'a jamais eu d'accident de
problèmes mécaniques ne s'en sortira
jamais dans cette montagne
pour daoud et son frère il est temps
d'attaquer la zone des 45 virage à
partir d'ici tout devient un problème
la route est extrêmement glissante
j'espère qu'il n'y aura pas trop de
neige fondue sinon ça sera l'enfer
[Musique]
franchir ces virages relève de l'épreuve
de force
l'enjeu est simple descendre sans jamais
s'arrêter et prier pour ne pas croiser
un autre camion dans les virages
m
il
[Musique]
la neige fondue a rendu la route boueuse
le moindre coup de frein un peu trop
brusque et le camion devient
incontrôlable
c'est le tout droit sur et dans le ravin
quand ça glisse je ne peux rien faire et
je suis obligé d'attendre que ça se
passe je ne peux pas freiné et si je le
fais le camion peut partir n'importe où
regarde j'arrive même pas à tourner le
volant ça sert à rien
oui c'est comme ça la vie ici
sa vie daoud la doit à la maîtrise
parfaite de son camion
mais ce qu'il ne maîtrise pas c'est la
colère de la nature comme les avalanches
qui arrache tout sur leur passage
ce poteau à haute tension en a récemment
fait les frais
[Musique]
regarde ça les avalanches ont arraché le
poteau électrique
et maintenant on a très peur des fils
qui pendent
mais en quoi c'est dangereux si on
touche les fils avec le toit du camion
ça fait fondre les pneus mais surtout ça
peut nous électrocuté
un dernier virage et les deux frères
arrivent enfin dans la vallée de chitral
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la route y est plutôt bonne elle est
goudronnée et protégés par des
contreforts cali pourra bientôt avoir sa
leçon de conduite
mais quelques kilomètres plus loin en
bas dans la vallée c'est une mauvaise
surprise qui les attend
[Musique]
une partie de la montagne est écroulé
sur la route
impossible d'aller plus loin
[Applaudissements]
c'est grave et oui regarde la montagne
s'écoule encore la route est
complètement bloqué il va falloir au
moins une journée entière à ce petit
tracteur pour tout déblayer
mais il n'existe pas une autre route non
malheureusement c'est la seule de la
vallée
[Applaudissements]
le flanc de la montagne reste instable
et un flot de rocher sans décroche
continuellement
dessous au péril de leur vie les
ouvriers travaillent sans relâche pour
réouvrir la route au plus vite est fait
attention
la machine ça coûte cher à l'hercules
faut bien je travaille un rocher se
décrochent
et percute l'avant du tracteur
pourquoi tu prends tous ces risques il
faut bien que quelqu'un le fasse ce
travail
allez j'y retourne
[Applaudissements]
de part et d'autre de l'éboulement en
file indienne
une trentaine de camions attendent que
le tracteur ouvre la route
certains sont bloqués depuis plusieurs
jours alors chacun prend son mal en
patience et fait passer le temps comme
il peut la route était déjà bloqué hier
soir depuis j'attends c'est un rêve
constamment c'est de la faute au
gouvernement qui n'entretient pas les
routes dans cette région pourtant on a
besoin pour travailler quand on va se
bloquer comme aujourd'hui on perd
beaucoup d'argent
un bien petit tracteur pour une si
grosse montagne
tout le monde attend l'arrivée du
bulldozer gouvernementale envoyé par la
ville de drogue situé à quelques
kilomètres de l'éboulement
[Applaudissements]
josh est connu dans tout le pakistan
pour la beauté de ses camions et ce
n'est pas un hasard
[Musique]
le village abrite l'atelier de
décoration le plus réputé de la vallée
sa mine and co une entreprise familiale
on y vient des quatre coins du pays pour
passer commande ou pour le simple
plaisir des yeux
la famille de sa mine donne une seconde
vie à ces camions qui datent pour la
plupart des années 60 lorsque le
véhicule arrive il est comme ça et votre
but est de le faire briller autant que
ce camion
combien ça coûte de faire ça ça dépend
de la quantité de décoration que le
propriétaire demande les prix vont de 15
à 2500 euros
mais plus ça brille plus c'est cher quel
est l'intérêt
ça donne de la valeur aux propriétaires
ça montre que les affaires vont bien ce
matin à l'atelier on termine la
fabrication d'une couronne un travail
minutieux qui demande de l'imagination
[Musique]
les couleurs et les motifs je les trouve
dans ma tête je fais comme j'aime
l'important pour le propriétaire
c'est que ce soit voyant
[Musique]
la couronne est prête elle peut venir
embellir le dessus de la cabine du
chauffeur
allez on lève la couronne pèse plus
d'une centaine de kilos et toute la
famille participe à son installation
bougent un peu sur la droite relève là
encore un peu avant on nous demandait
des décorations simple et uniquement à
l'intérieur de la cabine et aujourd'hui
ils en veulent par tous c'est énormément
de travail
le petit va faire ce métier non c'est un
métier trop difficile lui il va à
l'école
le propriétaire du camion vient
d'arriver
la tradition veut qu'il pose lui-même la
touche finale
il a investi plus de 350 euros de
décoration l'équivalent de sept mois de
salaire
banal anthony regarde j'ai mis des
décorations partout mais enceinte 1200
au pire et mon ventilateur
j'ai aussi mis un autoradio tout neuf la
décoration c'est très important pour les
affaires ça montre aux clients que
l'entreprise va bien
regarde ça c'est très joli
ça bouge quand on roule on est très
fiers d'avoir dépensé beaucoup d'argent
pour notre camion au village de dosches
un camion nouvellement décoré ne reste
jamais longtemps inaperçu et chacun y va
de son commentaire
il est pas mal mais pour moi c'est dans
le sud qui sont les plus beaux camions
mais de la musique mais de la musique et
montre nous que ça fonctionne très bien
[Musique]
ils dépensent rien pour la décoration
c'est important d'avoir un beau camion
c'est comme lorsqu'on épouser une femme
on veut qu'elle soit belle c'est la même
chose
qui sont les plus importants les femmes
ou les camions les femmes bien sûr ce
sont les femmes les plus importantes
alors rien de mieux pour séduire que de
prendre la pose devant son camion
[Musique]
le lendemain matin au pied de la
montagne écroulé le bulldozer tant
attendu est arrivé
en quelques coups de pelle il ouvre un
passage dans la coulée de pierre
pas bien travaillé
[Musique]
n'ont ils pas aussi libre ça peut encore
bouger
m
allez à vendre on a perdu assez de temps
de picon tu as ton de trois jours le
passage reste temporaire car la montagne
continue de s'écrouler
les pierres qui tombent les premiers
camions s'engagent les uns après les
autres
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
arrive le tour de daoud
son petit frère passe devant pour le
guider
tout s'est bien passé ils peuvent enfin
terminer leur voyage
[Musique]
daoud est fier de son petit frère qui
l'a aidé à franchir la montagne sans
casse ni accident il décide de le
récompenser
allez vas-y va prendre ma place
[Musique]
la route est facile maintenant alors je
le mets au volant pourquoi tu fais ça
il doit commencer à apprendre le métier
ça sera facile
[Applaudissements]
allez vas-y démarre
allez accélère
[Applaudissements]
tu sembles inquiet non non non tant que
je reste à côté de lui
tout ira bien
[Applaudissements]
je n'ai pas trop jeune pour conduire si
mais c'est le métier que je veux faire
et tu as peur dans la région pas d'école
de conduite
ce sont les aînés qui enseigne aux plus
jeunes
allez avance engage toi il n'ya personne
passe une vitesse
allez roule roule prendre la vitesse
passez une vitesse maintenant où tu vas
calais vas-y change
trop tard imbéciles freine maintenant tu
m'écoutes ou je te remets une ne lâche
pas ton volant petit con je te dis de ne
jamais lâché son volant c'est trop
dangereuse et allez c'est fini arrête
toi là maintenant aller derrière ce
camion c'est fini mais le frein à main
allez dehors des galas dégage des sens
il conduit bien alors ouais pas mal
quand même
il deviendrait conducteur alors s'il
reste avec moi encore deux ou trois ans
il pourra faire c'est pourquoi tu
frappes il lâche le volant c'est bien
trop dangereux de faire ça on risque
notre vie il doit s'en souvenir pour
toujours khalid et daoud arrive enfin à
chitral pour parcourir les 240
kilomètres de là lowery ils ont mis près
de quatre jours
il faut maintenant des charges est
rapidement la marchandise et reprendre
la route au plus vite pour tenter de
faire encore un aller retour avant la
fin du mois merci pour ton courage
allez encore un dernier sac et on rentre
on a bien travaillé dans son coin
khalid enterre ses illusions l'avis de
camionneurs il l'avait rêvé autrement
[Applaudissements]
chitral est la plus grande ville de la
vallée toutes les marchandises de
première nécessité ils sont stockés
avant de partir ravitailler les
villageois installés à flanc de montagne
le long de la frontière avec
l'afghanistan
le village de parent san se situe à 35
kilomètres à peine de chitral
[Musique]
accroché à 2900 mètres d'altitude ce
petit village est totalement enclavé
chasse agriculture élevage les 1500
habitants y vivent en autarcie
complètement isolée du reste du pakistan
pour rejoindre par san il n'existe
qu'une seule solution s'aventurer sur
cette route de pierre creusé depuis à
peine une dizaine d'années
[Musique]
retour à chitral dès les premières
heures de la journée les passagers se
pressent par dizaines à la gare centrale
chacun tente de trouver une place dans
l'un des véhicules à destination de son
village
ici c'est la gare des quatre cannes ce
sont les seuls véhicules capables de
franchir la montagne car les camions ne
passent pas hadji à 28 ans il conduit la
jeep qui mène au village de parent san
comme son père avant lui il assure
plusieurs fois par semaine la lourde
charge de transporter les villageois
aujourd'hui il doit remonter une famille
sur cette route réputée des plus
dangereuses mais son véhicule à un
problème mécanique
ça va aller
alors là ça fuit de partout là
ils ont besoin de moi au village je suis
le seul moyen de transport par exemple
si quelqu'un tombe malade
c'est à moi de m'en occuper et de le
transporter alors je dois faire réparer
la jeep le plus rapidement et repartir
au plus vite
[Musique]
malheureusement le problème est plus
important que prévu
une pièce de la transmission est
totalement usées regarda les fous tu ta
pièce tu as l'air inquiet oui c'est très
difficile de trouver une pièce comme
celle ci comment vas tu faire je ne sais
pas là j'ai un gros problème
[Musique]
trouver une pièce de précision dans un
village perdu au milieu de la montagne
relève du parcours du combattant
bonjour je cherche cette pièce on n'a
pas ça ici
[Musique]
bonjour tu as à toi non j'ai pas ce
genre de pièce laisse moi dormir
[Musique]
non non j'ai pas ce modèle rade chercher
tu trouveras jamais le salut viendra
peut-être de cette dernière boutique 2 4
6 8
c'est bon pour toi c'est la bonne pièce
ça fait 40 euros
[Musique]
deux heures plus tard la jeep réparé
prête pour affronter de nouveau la
montagne
[Musique]
hadji charge près d'une tonne de
marchandises mais aussi des passagers
sauf à nadi mois et ses parents ont le
sourire
après quinze jours d'hospitalisation
pour une grosse fièvre leur petite fille
peut enfin rentrer au village
[Applaudissements]
malgré les dangers on va remonter par
cette route il n'existe pas d'autres
accès au village tu te fais du souci
pour ta famille oui j'ai surtout peur
pour ma petite
[Musique]
bonne route
merci merci
par manque de place une dizaine de
personnes sont entassés à l'arrière de
la jeep privilège pour la famille hadji
les a installés à ses côtés on va mettre
un peu de musique
avant de s'engager dans la montagne il
faut franchir la rivière et rouler sur
un antique pont de bois
[Applaudissements]
alors
ce pont est très vieux il a été réparé
plusieurs fois mais il reste fragile
on n'aime pas le traverser écoute le
bruit qui le faire or
parce que moi
personne ne prend le risque de s'arrêter
dessus
après le pont tout l'enjeu du voyage est
d'atteindre le village avant la nuit
dormir dans les montagnes pourrait
s'avérer fatal pour le groupe
les températures chutent souvent dessous
de zéro et les avalanches de pierres
sont fréquentes
de nombreuses jeep se sont déjà fait
emporter
en l'honneur d'un ami tué par la route
azam se rend au village pour participer
à la fête des morts dans un accident ici
sur cette route ans et demi tour au dr
c'est la première fois que je vais
revoir son fils sa femme et sa mère la
route est terrible elle est vraiment
trop dangereuse par endroits on peut
glisser et tomber dans le ravin
or il vaut toujours 19e
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oui
à cette altitude la chaleur est
épouvantable en journée il fait au
minimum 40 degrés au soleil le copilote
tente régulièrement de refroidir le
moteur
après trois heures de route les
passagers sont exténués il n'avait pas
prévu cette chaleur non ma chérie
[Musique]
t'inquiète pas on va bientôt arriver on
va bientôt arriver et la soif la petite
on a plus d'eau
maintenant c'est l'endroit le plus
dangereux on doit passer le tunnel de la
mort qu'allah nous protège dieu est
grand il va nous aider à passer il le
faut
le tunnel de la mort est un passage
d'une dizaine de km creusés à la main sa
voûte est instable
les éboulements ils sont si fréquents
que des ouvriers le déblai chaque jour
[Musique]
dans la route a été construite deux
ouvriers sont morts ils ont glissé dans
le ravin et maintenant tout le monde a
peur de venir ici
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
une traversé sans encombre mais une
victoire de courte durée à la sortie du
tunnel de la mort la rivière est en crue
impossible de passer avec la jeep
il va falloir passer la nuit sur place
descend à la rivière va regarder
on a un gros problème
le courant est trop fort c'est
impossible de traverser maintenant je ne
pense pas qu'on passera aujourd'hui
inquiète la maman de solana ne sait plus
quoi penser
[Applaudissements]
quelques passages et intrépide tente
tout de même de franchir la rivière à
leurs risques et périls
c'est impossible je réussirai jamais
c'est infranchissable vraiment c'est
infranchissable un jeune téméraire
insiste à son tour
une rivière infranchissable une nuit
froide qui se rapproche les parents de
solana ne peuvent plus attendre
on part à pied on ne peut pas prendre le
risque de rester bloqué ici cette nuit
on a beaucoup de marche pour arriver
jusqu'à notre maison mais on n'a plus le
choix maintenant faut y aller
[Musique]
non
sous un soleil de plomb la famille
commence son ascension
[Musique]
or notre fille s'il te plaît un peu plus
cette voie secondaire uniquement
praticable à pied date de l'époque où la
route n'existait pas
inquiété par la montée des eaux le grand
père est descendu à la rencontre de sa
famille regarde ma chérie on voit la
maison là haut
en
il faut au minimum trois heures de
marche pour atteindre la maison
familiale
[Musique]
ça va ça va prend la petite avec moi ma
chérie couche là à les fatiguer comme ma
famille prend la route j'ai peur je ne
sait jamais s'ils vont arriver en vie
alors je descends toujours à leur
rencontre pour les attendent au bord de
la route et les aider s'ils ont un
problème comme aujourd'hui et maintenant
tout va bien je suis rassuré voilà s'il
te plaît il faut qu'elle dorme elle est
très fatiguée
à l'extérieur le père de famille a déjà
repris le tissage de la laine
il utilise une méthode ancestrale qui
n'a pas changé depuis des siècles en
dise la laine à la maison puis on
descend là vendredi
c'est comme ça que l'on gagne un peu
d'argent il n'y a pas d'autre solution
dans le village lalem sera vendu 2 euros
le mètre sur le marché de chitral tout
juste de quoi acheter quelques vêtements
pour la famille et payer les voyages
angie
devant le guet l'espoir est revenu le
niveau de l'eau redescend peu à peu et
pour faciliter le passage des jeeps les
villageois tapissent le lit de la
rivière avec des cailloux
au courant est toujours très fort on
peut pas encore passé alors on jette des
pierres
tu sens sans égal
allez on y va de soi sans pousser encore
pousser
et là c'est bien on va pouvoir passer je
suis content car au polar
j'ai fait descendre des passagers c'est
trop dangereux
là
allez remonter
on y va
[Musique]
après quelques kilomètres le village de
parent ça n'apparaît enfin
passe moi un sac de sucre s'il te plaît
hadji a mis dix heures pour parcourir 35
km mais il a le sourire car une fois de
plus il a réussi à tromper la mort je
suis heureux j'ai rejoint mon village
mes amis ma famille dieu a été avec nous
encore une fois
[Musique]
plus haut dans le village azzam a
rejoint la maison où va se dérouler la
fête des morts il y est accueilli par le
fils du défunt
salut mon ami comment ça va tu vas bien
mes condoléances pour ton père merci
merci et ta mère comment va-t-elle que
dieu ait son âme elle est morte
que s'est il passé bah quelques mois
après l'accident de papa elle est parti
à son tour et à son âme
étonnamment c'est dans les coins les
plus reculés du pakistan que les femmes
sont les plus libres ici la religion est
présente mais elle est suivie avec plus
de souplesse
regarde c'est les dernières photos de
mon père j'étais dans la jeep moi aussi
ce jour là le conducteur n'a pas
enclenché les quatre roues motrices et
la voiture s'est renversée
c'est comme ça que mon père est mort tu
as été blessés non moi et les autres
passagers nous n'avons pour la cérémonie
des morts nawa sacrifie l'une de ses
plus belles chèvres allez viens ici
voilà on va prendre celle ci elle est
grande
bien dodu elle va être parfaite
[Musique]
je te remercie allah d'accepter ce
sacrifice
nous allons sacrifier cette chèvre en
tongs
passe moi le couteau s'il te plaît il
faut vraiment bien aiguisé son couteau
pour que la chèvre ne souffrent pas et
ses péchés de la faire souffrir un
sacrifice doit honorer l'animal vient
m'aider s'il te plaît salut les pattes
arrière allez vas-y tu peux y aller les
peaux sont très importantes pour nous
car avec qu'on fabrique des tambours
mais aussi des couvertures extrêmement
chaude et même lorsqu'on porte de
lourdes charges on les pose sur nos
épaules elle nous les protège et on
fabrique aussi des chaussures pour
l'hiver de très bonnes chaussures même
car grâce à elle on ne glisse pas dans
la neige
on prépare personnellement le repas une
trentaine d'hommes sont attendus ce soir
[Musique]
j'attends
les musiciens entament les premiers
chants en l'honneur du défunt une ode à
leur route qui malgré les morts les
relie au reste du pays
[Musique]